they say that many of the African
American leaders are not for this I'm
here today to say I am for a long as
25th thousands gathered in downtown Los
Angeles to sound off on a revolutionary
school choice resolution being voted on
by the school board that oversees the
nation's second largest district I think
that every parent deserves choice the
worst phrase that I'd heard applied to
this is freedom of choice for far too
long the majority of parents across la
haven't had that choice freedom of
choice was a favorite word of southern
favorite phrase of southern
segregationists I'm here on behalf of
thousands of parents who are in support
of the resolution for choice today I
stand here asking for a right to choose
my future they don't have choices to go
anywhere else LA Unified is one of the
worst school districts in the nation the
resolution would give students in some
of la's lowest performing schools the
choice to attend charter schools
charters our public schools often run by
private nonprofit organizations that
give teachers and principals more local
control we are finding a way with zlotys
charters to build better serve our
students they come for one purpose and
one purpose only to receive education
many traditional public school teachers
and union members protested the
resolution my opinion on charter schools
first of all I am categorically opposed
to them AJ Duffy is president of the
teachers union UT la UT LA has been in
the forefront of reform we already have
many choices and many innovative
programs in this district get away from
this and start saying if the charters
have learned things that we need to know
you need to make that district policy I
could actually stand here and say ditto
I parents want change and they want
change now the resolution is about the
parents who are sick and tired of being
sick and tired for 40 years parents have
been trying to improve the schools that
they go to we're not going to wait any
longer we're going to keep faxing we're
going to keep calling we're going to
keep clogging up the streets because
these are our kids that we
love we don't have forever to wait we
only want and deserve the best for our
children